moi c'était dans un avion dans un avion
et deux lignes Paris New York
américain
de ceux qui ont fait dans les avions ça
s'appelle
ah oui les enfants allez manger une
Danette dans la cuisine
maman va raconter quelque chose à tonton
[Applaudissements]
dans un avion non mais par contre j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un dans un avion mon
voisin et à la fin du du trajet
transatlantique on s'est embrassé
en train de manger leur Danette au lieu
de rencontre tu peux y aller tu peux y
aller toi avion je pense que je l'ai
déjà fait et sinon taxi taxi à New
yorking
[Rires]
bordel de merde c'est bon là j'ai pas
son tarif ça vous faites vite fait cette
connerie
et donc on a un trajet entre sceaux et à
Paris
la boulette en fait
d'accord Boulogne il y avait un peu
romantique
le Ghana ou enfin en tout cas il a fait
comme si le voyait pas et le gars même
l'odeur
le gars sorti son zigouni dans le taxi
oui enfin après c'est un vieux souvenir
mais
tu imagines comment ça je t'attends
Gilles Verdez mes habitudes
comme tous les jours
alors à côté du musée du Louvre à Paris
dans le parc des Tuileries
pendant quelques mois j'ai eu mes
habitudes là-bas c'est à dire un endroit
où on venait batifoler fin des années 80
début 90 et j'avais mes habitudes dans
un bosquet
avec tout l'anglais qui l'a mis c'est
donner un arbre le 11 mai
j'adore j'ai l'impression d'être dans
cette vieille mission rappeler ou pas la
chance
on est avec Frédéric Bouchard
Tintin
la dernière fois mais
non non
la terrasse d'une chambre d'hôtel sur la
terrasse d'une chambre d'hôtel
j'ai la chance d'avoir des propriétés
partout
[Applaudissements]
donc voilà molo l'asticot quoi tu vois
voilà c'est bon
une branche bizarre un moment
et tu étais comment tu étais sur le
parapet et puis l'autre il était
je cherche pour l'instant pour l'instant
mets-toi en haut jusqu'à 19h10
est-ce que est-ce que ma meuf regarde
et est-ce que ma meuf va se reconnaître
dans cet endroit donc est-ce que je
donne à un vrai endroit que j'ai fait
avec ma meuf ou est-ce que je donne un
autre endroit que j'ai fait il y a très
très longtemps
moi j'aime bien alors j'ai un top 3
salon de toilettage
[Rires]
tu t'es
Responsable de salon donc j'avais
l'opportunité d'aller dans le sang
il y a pas de mots elles sont toutes des
photos
[Rires]
elle a quel âge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai bien aimé mais le mieux
c'est chocolaterie pendant Pâques
ça c'est bien pendant Pâques mais quoi
il est avec il est avec tous les
commerçants de son quartier
bah c'est pas un gars que c'est nana qui
est de chez Léonidas bien sûr c'est pas
un gars c'est la fille de nilas non non
non
je connais très bien
et alors non mais alors je me suis bien
amusé ouais je me suis amusé j'avais des
plans comme ça patinoire piscine j'ai
pas vous montrer ton géandouillard c'est
les meilleurs c'est ce que je préfère
de Bruges
[Rires]
non non je suis très basique les je
dirais l'arrière d'une voiture l'arrière
d'une voiture
[Rires]
toujours tendance à oublier oh c'est
quand même clair bordel de merde
2023 ni en 2024 ni pour les JO ah oui
voilà oui mais vous pouvez avoir du
désir quand même bah t'inquiète pas
c'est pas pour toi
t'emmerde pas avec ça va vous êtes un
homme quoi je suis un homme mais je suis
surtout votre patron
donc si vous payez fermez votre gueule
ça m'arrangerait